the jurgen experience to me it's all
about body language and all about sort
of and this is why you know i'm so into
horses and dog training and stuff like
that and horse bodies didn't try to save
some bears while you're out here i did
texas i [ __ ] love texas for whitney
about bears i love you guys
there she's saving bears out here she's
mad at people i'm like whoa
i love having fights already i [ __ ]
love texas but when you're when you have
texas and west virginia but you're ready
to fight anyone at any time
right and there are a lot there's an
incredible amount of
uh animal cruelty in texas that i
that to me is against what texas is all
about like putting bears in boxes
what was it called the central capital
it was called the capital texas zoo it's
right [ __ ] out here
there's bears in cages the ones that the
chinese uh
use to do the gallbladders take them you
know like the
gallbladder some medicine and
they're in these cages and there's no
water you mean black bears is that what
you're saying i'll show you
it must be a black bear yes i got the
name you know that gallbladder thing is
like
it's so bad that they you're not allowed
to even if you legally hunt a bear
you can't open up its uh its organ
cavity because
people are worried that people are
shooting bears just for their
gallbladders in british columbia that's
right uh
the asiatic black bear and this uh
[ __ ]
uh capital of texas zoo which is trying
to say it's like rescuing them
is all about the asiatic black bears of
species whose population is rapidly
decreasing due to illegal hunting for
its gallbladder which is used in
asian folk medicine and then you're
going to [ __ ] put it in a box and not
give it any water that pisses me off and
it's a usda violation so i go around to
these like [ __ ]
seeing cats are you calling these people
out publicly right now on this podcast
i guess i just did didn't i these
[ __ ] here's what you want to
know why this is a real problem for them
you understand that right you just like
opened hell's door it's a real problem
for me because these [ __ ] have
guns
at all times and it's it is a really
dangerous
thing to for me to be into remember i
did it with the giraffe and those
[ __ ] crooks in in la and most of it i
do privately yeah malibu
[ __ ] so sorry big out here like
how did you find out about this i found
out about it because i'm in a pretty
like hardcore
group of people that try to rescue
people they try to shut down
uh illegal behavior zoos roadside zoos
because
and i know it's like whitney's crazy she
loves animals like it gives a [ __ ]
to me once i started learning uh the
statistics on whenever there's exotic
animal trafficking it's usually
accompanied by human trafficking
it's all the same people so when you see
a lion running free in houston or
lion private ownership of lions tigers
bears any apex predator
there's usually you know teenagers from
another country in the same truck
so it's like it's like dog fighting it's
like people are like oh it's just dog
fighting who cares
that's that's what's in the front yard
but if you see that in the front yard go
into the [ __ ] basement and see what
else is [ __ ] going on
so that's what that's what um the top
three uh most profitable black market
businesses right it's arms
drugs and then human slash animal
trafficking
so it's the same people no one trafficks
jaguars and doesn't throw in a couple
people you know what's weird pause and
think about this for a second
it's weird how we have uh associations
with animals where there's acceptable
torture and death
and some where it's not and with exotic
animals we're especially sensitive
especially sensitive to the idea of
killing bears or putting bears in cages
but if you found out the chickens are in
the cage right next door you're like
well that's a chicken factory they're
making they're making mcnuggets i think
i and they're delicious put some honey
on that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and i think i know i think what is that
i can say well
my because when you see an apex predator
a lion tiger or bear that's so
incredibly strong
you know how much abuse had to go into
containing that animal because they're
so
incredibly strong you know michael
jackson i mean the [ __ ] [ __ ] in la
bob dunn i'm going to say it
who puts chimpanzees in cages uh so that
they don't build any muscle
if you're seeing a chimpanzee a lion
tiger or bear in a cage
they were they had to um they got to be
on fentanyl there on all these drugs
uh natasha daly wrote a really amazing
fentanyl oh yeah the ones entitled
chimps on fentanyl oh they put them in
cages like this so that they don't grow
any muscle
yeah and any chimp like michael
jackson's chimps there were three of
each
because they don't have the same name
when they well there's chubs yes there
was like a chubs wanna chubs too
and then a bubbles one and two because
after a year you can't hold a chimp in a
tuxedo it's going to rip your face off
right
just beat your ass yes so after about a
year they send it off to
experiments there's one actually in a
zoo in armadillo texas one of the chubs
i know where all michael jackson's
[ __ ] animals are like that's
that's my [ __ ] hunting what yes yeah
you know where all of michael jackson's
like all of them i mean a lot of them
were sold for experiments
oh geez elephants are kind of spread out
yeah one of them they were sold for
experiments
the chimps were like lipstick what kind
of experiments i mean chimp experiments
space odyssey sequel yeah
but uh yeah i mean it's a big a lot of
colleges and universities the ones that
are [ __ ] waiting around for
their student loans for imprisoning
people financially do a lot of
experiments on college campuses
so i don't do a lot of this publicly
because i'll get murdered imagine you go
from living in the [ __ ] castle
living in the michael jackson neverland
castle to getting experiments done on
you and you don't understand english
and you're like what is happening like i
thought i had the life going and the
[ __ ] life now i'm strapped in and
they're
experimenting on me i went from being
[ __ ] by michael jackson
to being probed you know in texas
what the [ __ ] it was but chimps you know
i mean they get so [ __ ] strong they
have to keep them in cages so their
muscles don't build they don't feed them
any protein and then they inject them
with
you know i mean uh uh there's one uh
university which i'm not gonna say right
now because i'm like
getting all my [ __ ] ducks in a row
but they put botox in their muscles so
they don't develop any muscles
did i ever tell you about the time i
went to a tiger place in thailand brutal
did i tell you about this no i did we
did a bunch of animal things me and my
family in thailand we did one of them
that was really cool
we uh we hung around with elephants and
you fed them and i had it on my
instagram page you give them sugar cane
you wash them and then
as long as you're not riding them and no
you do ride them okay but they want you
to ride them they like let you
you weigh as much as one of those stupid
hats with cigarettes in it
that's what you weigh to an elephant but
i didn't like it yeah what they have to
do to get them that compliant
is pretty brutal you know not in this
place
okay this place first of all these
animals are completely wide open
and they're free-ranging sheldrick trust
does a great job too if they raise them
from being babies
they do that but they also take animals
from circuses and reintroduce them to
the wild
because while you're walking with these
elephants they just grab a tree and
start eating it like they can do
whatever the [ __ ] they want
and they're they're so not intimidated
by you in any way
and the relationship that the trainers
had with the elephants was love
it was all petting positive
reinforcement sugar cane
they gave them food and they and they
were always washing them
and when you have this they did it very
smartly because a lot of these elephants
if you reintroduce them to the wild
they'll die right away and the other
elephants will actually kill them but
this place in thailand they have they
have successfully reintroduced many to
the wild and one of the things that they
did is
you don't just ride the elephant you
have a relationship with it yes that's
it
so you they they bring you over like
this is the elephant you're going to
have a relationship with
and you're going to feed him sugar cane
and wash him so i'm
handing them sugar cane they take it
gently with their trunks
they're sweets well that's amazing i
don't do you remember the name of this
place because i always love to promote
remember we stayed in chiang mai and it
was us
hour maybe outside of that not not that
far away but the way they did it was it
was
all about like what you paid for for
that experience would go
towards funds to help these animals and
reintroduce them to the wild and also
get them
from circuses and rescue them from some
other places
i didn't like the writing part i would
say my my but everybody else wanted to
do it but
my thought was like i just want i like
to feed you and i'll wash you i want to
be your friend i don't need to get on
top and be like we
i'm riding you that's a language
elephants understand you know
and and i think that the really shitty
places which is most of them give the
good ones a bad name which sucks i went
to one
i went to koh samui uh and i don't
remember in thailand where
i went to one and there's you know you
go there and everyone's riding them and
then you look down and there's just
chains
between their feet and i just it killed
me it crushed me because i thought i was
going to this amazing sanctuary because
anyone can put sanctuary in the front of
their [ __ ] thing but
i think i've heard you talk so much
about um you know captivity of you know
dolphins and
it's just when you see that and when
you're like this is just intolerable
like yeah these animals are not designed
to be in it's prison you're watching
this incredible thing being present and
you know that this [ __ ] the
second it gets out could kill
everyone within a 50 mile radius the
fact that they're in this cage
what had to happen in order to confine
them that way i mean what happened for
someone to put you in a cage they'd have
to [ __ ]
shoot you with darts they you know so
it's so heartbreaking
to see powerful animals be reduced to
a [ __ ] zoo exhibition a shelf trinket
it's sick and look and a lot of animal
people are
[ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] and you know as we
say animal people aren't always people
people because a lot of people that are
real big in animal rescue have a lot of
childhood trauma
they were neglected they were abused as
kids and they see something voiceless
and that can't you know send emails or
make phone calls
being abused and they go [ __ ] nuts so
i don't [ __ ] with a lot of animal rescue
people because they're not rational
my thing is like let's focus on changing
a law instead of trying to get every
[ __ ] elephant out of every zoo
um but uh you know i think that you know
someone like you
uh i think we're similar and that we see
how [ __ ] up it is to have an apex
predator in a box
yeah um we went to the the elephant
thing
and the elephant thing was it was it
actually felt good
because these elephants they they they
came over the top of the hill
they just showed up out of nowhere
there's no fences they came over the top
of the hill and they come
when they know that they're going to
bring out the sugar cane and they're
going to meet these people and they're
choosing to do it
and the way they meet you they just walk
right up to you i'm telling you it's
it's wild
like they just they bump into you like
they bring their face to you and you pet
them you go hello
because they love nice to meet you yeah
they like being pat are they the
smartest animal after chimpanzee
i believe well they can paint they might
be smarter than chimps
you know like they can they can paint
things they can't solve complex puzzles
like chimps do
chimps can spell things chimps can do a
lot of stuff but
they remember their uh their loved ones
their family members for like
they have few decades and decades it it
kills me they've reintroduced ones
after like you know more than 10 years
apart and they recognize each other
instantly and they
run and hug and they're they're rubbing
trunks and everything it's dinosaurs
well there's something they're the
closest we have to [ __ ] dinosaurs and
you look at them and you're
you know and i there's this place
pawsark that i don't think they've been
around that long
interesting i mean but they feel like
well they're they move
like it is like jurassic park it's
special there's something special it's
snuffle up against yeah i mean it's also
like
the fact that something exists like that
that's so goddamn big
and yet it'll like if you're nice to it
gentle like
here's the thing it's like you really
can't keep a [ __ ] tiger as a pet in
an open area
but you can in thailand with these
elephants like the the relationship they
have with people is very different like
that thing just walks up to you
you can pet it there is not a [ __ ]
chance in hell you could do that with a
tiger
that's not a chance in hell you would
let one of your friends or your children
get on a tiger i mean and if they do
anyone touching any apex predator that's
abuse they have to take
the uh cub from the mom right away they
have to dart the mom with the
tranquilizer tick because
when everyone's like i'm holding a bear
cub i'm holding a tire cup it's like you
think that the mom just [ __ ]
willingly gave that [ __ ] up
no and then it's not getting any of the
breast milk so they have all these
autoimmune issues and they
their spines don't develop properly so
the place that i
uh work with in alpine it's all these um
bears that have been cut
in cub petting as adults and they can't
really walk well
they're all [ __ ] up it's once you see
the aftermath
of what happens with any kind of tiger i
mean they have about
six months and they just sent them off
to either get killed or to get uh
uh can hunting or whatever that stuff is
where they just put it
on tigers they put a tiger or a
lion that's never been in the wild
that's only been held by humans
they definitely do that with lions in
africa and these canned hunting
facilities and the lions he's a person
is like hey what's up and then someone
shoots it
exactly and you're like that's not
hunting that's not that's [ __ ]
fishing not only that
the lion doesn't go very far from where
they release it because it doesn't have
a territory
and it's like oh i'm about to get a big
mac from this human i don't think they
think that
or sorry they go that's a big man i
think immediately if they see a person
they want to kill it
but maybe the point is it's like it's
not really hunting it's not like you're
going into the wild animals they
literally let it go a day or two before
the hunt
but you've seen tippy hedren and these
things where they they bottle raise them
so they're not going to attack someone
that bottle raised them or i don't think
they do that on those farms
have you ever seen um uh louis theroux
his documentary
i love him too i've had him on a couple
times and i love his yeah
the scientology one no he's been on a
couple times i love him but he had a
great special that he did about
going to these hunting camps in africa
where they raise these animals
specifically to be released and hunted
and uh he stayed there for a long time
like he's so
thorough he he got in with this guy and
got very close with this guy that was
running this and he got him irritated
to the point where the guy was like
afraid he's
[ __ ] and this this guy was talking
about why he did it
and he's like it's [ __ ] and he's like
you know these animals are [ __ ]
and he was basically explaining the only
way these animals have any value
is if they're worth money to kill that's
why there's high populations of them
which is really wild because they used
to be on the verge of extinction
a lot of them and they've regrown their
numbers substantially
just because there's businesses that are
designed so that people can
that's the guy so people can go over
there and hunt these animals catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience